elle claque journaliste indépendant
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir
ni claques merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur france boris johnson de
retour et il est attendu selon vous au
tournant sinon il est attendu au
tournant
il est assez mal at on a été très malade
même du coffee tease 9 il est de retour
aujourd'hui et il n'était pas très
réaliste de s'attendre à ce qu'ils
disent que le confinement serait levé
avant le 3 mai est la date indiquée pour
le bilan du confinement wade cependant
il ya bien des qu'il y aurait des
discussions au cours des prochaines
journées sur d'avenir et il est
important de comprendre que le
confinement ce n'est pas un jeu gagnant
perdant c'est à dire que le confinement
a également causé des morts les gens ne
vont pas à l'hôpital pour des problèmes
qu'ils ont qu'ils sont pas les
coronavirus peut s'agir de hauts de
cancer tous les dix quinze cac et cela
signifie que des personnes vont mourir
de ses constantes
ce n'est pas son personnel à la décision
de lever le confinement implique
beaucoup de paramètres
car si on laisse trop souvent et trop
fortement alors il pourrait y avoir un
renforcement du nombre d'infections
peut-être mais s'il me fait rien et
qu'on continue de la sorte alors il y
aurait bien sûr des grands percussions
économique et ils eurent également des
morts lire confinement donc c'est très
très compliqué affectivement c'est une
voix qu'on n'a pas l'habitude en france
c'est vrai que
en france en général ça soit les hommes
politiques ou les français sont
davantage vouloir pousser au confinement
rejoint de confondre le nombre de
parents qui soit garder leurs enfants à
la maison au lieu de les mettre à partir
du 11 mai donc différent au royaume uni
où l'opposition et notamment les
milliers d'affaires en passant par les
rangs des partis conservateurs font un
petit peu de pression sur le premier
ministre
justement pour plus de souplesse
comment vous expliquez ça c'est tout
simplement dans la culture très libérale
britannique effectivement c'est
fascinant car des personnes à gauche
l'iso les capitalistes des vols de
déconfinement il veut le ramener les
travailleurs au travail il le mettre en
danger mais c'est trop simpliste
les capitalistes sont partagés les
banques et les financiers considèrent
comme le confinement serait meilleur
pour le pays de toutes les entreprises
les petites et moyennes sont prises au
fil des dettes c'est qu'ils ne
réussiront pas à payer quand les bacs
récupérons six entreprises donc pour ces
personnes elles sont plutôt à l'aise
avec raffinement alors en tout cas rien
à ma qui a qui a changé son fusil
d'épaulé si j'ose dire c'est boris
johnson ans au début on s'en souvient on
voyait assez désinvolte ans le premier
ministre vis-à-vis de cette épidémie de
corey may virus de pluie il a contracté
la maladie ils sont nés remis et il
paraît beaucoup plus prudent d'ailleurs
il appelle les britanniques à la
patience 1 vous êtes étonnés par ce
changement d'attitude c'est parce qu'il
a été malade selon vous pense
qu'effectivement la maladie la fop a
changé car le 5 mars effectivement il
était à la télé et il minimisé le virus
il évoquait même l'idée qu'on pourrait
simplement le
c'est se propager d'un boîtier il a dit
qu'il continuerait à serrer la main des
gens le 5 mars au store une semaine plus
tard il était bien plus sérieuse dans
une conférence de presse il a été plus
ferme plus sobre a dit beaucoup ta femme
ans ils vont perdre dans cette recherche
ces unités plus tard et puis ensuite
encore une semaine après il a le
confinement effectivement la maladie l'a
changée et j'entends dire que le cabinet
britannique utiliser les colons une
balise un allègement du conflit
ils veulent que le gouvernement dit
aussi c'est comme dernière nous avons
commencé leur étonnement et les faucons
disent non il est trop tôt devant être
prudent et continuer le confinement dans
l'avenir proche donc c'est une lutte au
sein du gouvernement en ce moment-même
effectivement c'est vraiment fascinant
il ya différentes opinions cintu la
population était leur fille demande
comment j'ai les y fait des victimes
il faut garder cela à l'esprit ces gens
qui ne sont ni un gamin donc l'impact
économique est la base de notre société
et sur notre santé avec leur chômage par
exemple qui est mauvais pour la santé
générale
gatti fin confiance se poursuivre et les
codes nécessaires et nous venons
d'appendre que ça monsieur gentili est
d'environ 300 ce qu'il entrait pour la
terre prépare à ce qui s'est passé avant
donc nous pensons que 23 mai y aura une
grande décision importante concernant la
fin du confinement a effectivement vous
avez raison car le royaume uni qui a
enregistré aujourd'hui 360 décès
supplémentaires en 24 heures soit que le
plus faible bilan depuis mars merci à
vous d'avoir été avec nous en direct
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir